When Olympic gold medalist, Tom Daley
was spotted crocheting at the Tokyo games this summer,
the world went crochet crazy!
And lucky for us, here on our show,
we've been crochet crazy that's right,
because it all started with our next guest,
crochet prodigy Jonah Larson
has been a friend of this show and mine,
since the very beginning. Do you see that?
That's he and I during the pilot,
I just loved and respected him so much,
and we became very close and he first
captured our hearts with his amazing crochet videos.
But more importantly, it's who Jonah is
that really inspires me.
Here's his story so you understand too.
(upbeat music)
Jonah Larson. Oh, he is such an amazing soul.
And he's the crocheting phenom
taking the needle point world by storm.
Jonah and I met and we became fast friends.
Look! Remember back when we could hug?
Jonah's wise beyond his years,
he authored his first book at 11
and he helped create a new library
in the Ethiopian village he was born in.
Thank you Jonah, we love you.
He is an inspiration to me
and I think we have so much to learn from him.
He's so knowledgeable too,
and he has great taste in movies and TV,
he's so well-read.
The award-winning, life affirming,
cross stitching, Jonah Larson.
(applause)
For the first time in two years,
I get to see him in person.
Please welcome my dear friend, Jonah Larson.
(applause and uplifting music)
Oh Jonah, I'm so happy to see you.
I'm so glad to be back.
Oh my gosh. This has been such a long journey.
It is, and before we get started,
I have to start this, I always start with
hello, crochet friends.
(applause)
What did you think about the crochet world
hitting the Olympics and like Olympics X crochet?
It was so cool to see Tom Daley,
the gold medal winning diver crocheting
because it really brings crochet
to a whole new generation of younger folks,
and it shows that it's for everyone,
not just the grandma hobby it's for men
and everyone else included.
And I think maybe crochet might even be
an Olympic sport one day
because of the hand dexterity needed.
(applause)
Well, of course you know I was watching Tom Daley
the whole time thinking of you,
and he knew that you were going to be on the show today,
so he has a message for you.
Oh wow.
Hi Jonah, it's Tom Daley here, Olympic diver,
but also fellow stitching enthusiast.
And I just wanted to say how awesome I think you are.
One, your designs are amazing, but secondly,
you're just incredible and you're so fast,
and able to talk at the same time
as doing all of those stitches,
and the way that you speak so eloquently about it,
and how much happiness and joy you bring to so many people.
One day, I hope I'm going to be able to meet you
and we can have a real sit down and we can have a stitch.
I can knit, crochet, we can all have a lovely time,
but in the meantime, keep doing what you're doing.
I think you're awesome.
Crochet away friends.
(applause)
You know, I thought it was cool
when I won 20 blue ribbons on my local state fair.
And now I'm rethinking that.
(laughter)
That's pretty baller that Tom Daley is saying...
That is super cool.
Your theme, your term, crochet away.
Yeah, that was pretty cool, I wasn't expecting that.
Okay, so a big part of who you are,
you know, is that you give back to meaningful causes
and recently you completed a big project in Ethiopia.
And can you tell us about it?
I'll start with the little origin story and backstories.
So when I was six months old,
I was adopted from a very rural area in Ethiopia that didn't
have a library, science lab, or a school altogether, really.
And I've been working with thousands of people,
and you too, because you helped me build.
And I was able to build a library that services
over 2000 students and has 3000 books,
and I've also been able to give them a science lab.
And now they received an award called
The Federal Medallia for Academic Excellence
from the Ethiopian government.
(applause)
I mean, Jonah, you were adopted in Ethiopia
and like, what is it that makes you be the kind of person
that says I want to give back to that community?
Well, I have to give the credit to my mom
over there in mint shirt because she is the one.
There she is! Hi, how are you?
(applause)
And I heard that you also still have
some big plans for the school as well.
The school has received an award for academic excellence,
but it's still not up to hygiene standards yet.
And they have a outhouse that doesn't meet their needs,
and it's not good for those children.
So right now I'm working on building
latrines for them, so that females,
they can have their privacy.
So they can attend school all the time
and get a good education.
And you have a Go Fund Me,
and you have a...
I have a Go Fund Me in the website,
jonahhands.com and I've already raised
1500 for this part of the project,
but I still have 5,500 to go.
Okay, well thank you for bringing
the awareness and attention to everything that you do Jonah.
Now back to crocheting,
we have a few audience members here,
and I'm so excited to introduce a new segment we're calling
'Crochet and A'.
(harp music and applause)
All righty here, we're going to go to our first question.
It's to Carmen, Let's see...
Carmen, there you are Carmen!
Welcome to the show.
Thank you, Hi Jonah, my question is,
I'm trying to get my daughter into crocheting,
to get excited to crochet with me.
Is there a go-to project that you can tell us about,
that's for beginners?
The project I would recommend is,
it's actually a hat pattern that I made.
It's a pattern from yourowninspirations.com,
you can find it'll be up on Drew Barrymore's website
it uses a chunkier yarn, so that way,
you can use a big hook and it goes faster,
and it's also easier to start for a beginner,
so I recommend using that hat to start with your daughter.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
Thank you so much, alright.
Next, we're going to Natalie.
Hi Jonah.
Hello.
So I love to crochet,
but I really want to get my husband more involved.
So how can we get more men involved in crochet,
just in general?
You know, the best way to answer that,
is to just send the video over, Tom Daley.
So that just shows you that it's for everyone,
and so that's my take on it.
Thank you.
Alright, we have one last question from Kelly,
please stand up. Oh, hi Kelly. How are you?
Hi. Hey Jonah.
Hello.
So, my question is how do you combine
your love for crocheting,
with your love for giving back to others?
The way I do that is by using my crochet
to raise money for causes. For example,
I sometimes make items and then auction off a blanket
and however much money it raises, I give it to my charities.
And then other times I'd do events with organizations
like just recently I did one
with an organization called Hats and Mittens,
which gives hats and mittens sets
to the kids in need in Minneapolis.
So there's so many different things you can do
to combine the love of crafting and being a fiber artist
with giving back, and I make sure I just do that
every single time I stitch.
Excellent. Okay.
Thank you guys so much for your thoughtful questions.
(applause)
That is just so wonderful.
Okay now Jonah, before we go,
I just want to say that our show
wants to give you the remaining 5,500
for your Go Fund Me page, which will complete...
(applause)
the money you need to complete the school.
Thank you so much...
That's going to help a lot of kids in Ethiopia,
I just need to let you know that.
All right. Thank you, Jonah so much.
(outro music)